hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game it was played in the finals of
the 2018 speed chess championship and
chess calm and it's a game between Cara
Nakamura with the white pieces and
Wesley so and now you've already seen
that Nakamura defeated 11 Arjun in the
semifinals and the Wesley so has
defeated young Judah also in the
semi-final so this is the clash in the
finals we're gonna talk about the
results of the match after you see this
game but it's really a wonderful game so
I really do hope you enjoy it and sorry
about - no video yesterday I'm preparing
something that I'm sure pretty much all
of you are going to enjoy and I'm
spending a lot of time preparing it so
but we're gonna get back to that in some
two days so also I will include a link
to this article and chess that come by
Peter Dodgers it will be in the
description below so feel free to check
that out as well now without further ado
let's check out this very nice game so
Nakamura has the white pieces and he
opens with E 4 we have E 5 Knight to f3
Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5 so the
rule opus is on the board sorry about
that
a 6 more fees defense we have better
captures D captures and now castles and
here there are a lot of moves possible
here like Bishop to e6 Bishop to d6 are
possible f6 has been played but here we
have Queen to f6 a very nice move by
Wesley that pretty much forces a queen
trade with the idea that Bishop is
coming to g4 and here you want to trade
the bishop for the night and also trade
Queens and while white can prevent this
with something like h3 then black will
simply develop and after something like
b3 h 6 1982 black can go queenside
castle and black will actually have a
very nice game with a lot of development
so I'm sure it can be played but most
most people don't do this
so d3 is played by nakamura we have
Bishop to d6 Knight bTW 297 and now
comes Knight to c4 a very nice move
threatening the bishop on d6 and also
putting more pressure on the pawn on e5
Bishop to g4 as planned now Western
wants to exchange Queens
we have h3 Bishop captures on f3 Queen
captures on f3 Queen captures ji
captures and here this move was played a
few times before in this position has
has been reached by several other
players but here after castles we have a
completely new game on our hands and the
Nakamura goes for f4 we have a captures
on f4 Knight captures on d6 this was
pretty much planned C captures on d6 and
now Bishop captures on f4 and here after
all is said and done you have you have
an endgame where the material on the
board is equal both players with to pawn
islands differences that there are four
points on the Queen side and three
points on the King set for Wesley and
this huge pawn chain stretching from
eight f4 he Caro and then an isolated H
bone on the King side and of course a
brush up against tonight so we'll see
how it goes
rook a to d8 and by Wesley and here we
have rook to e1 we have looked to d7 you
could push it immediately but then you
have to calculate what happens if the
bishop to c7 or Bishop to g5 so here
putting the rook to a nice light square
avoids any needed need for calculations
bushra back to g3 I will be 5 now comes
f3 and now f6 enforcing d5 square but
also making room for the King to be able
to enter the game rope to e2 we have
King to f7 and now rook 81 Nakamura
doubles on the e-file we have g5 and now
comes t5f captures on e5 rook captures
on e5 we have h6 enforcing the the g5
pawn f4 and now although it seems like
Wesley's position is much more passive
the rooks aren't really doing all that
much the knight is not all that
impressive on e7 and he karo has a very
nicely doubled rooks and the e-file so
doesn't really it doesn't really seem
like blacks as much but Wesley is
actually able to play this out he simply
plays Knight to g6 attacks the rook also
comes with a double attack against the
f4 pawn and here if white simply
retreats with the rook this rook is
coming to b7
he's controlling isse Evan and it will
be very easy to trade material here so
Nakamura decides the trade material his
own way look to a5 check King to g7 and
now comes Luke captures on f8 King
captures on f8 and now F captures on g5
h capture son g5 and now again we have a
position where there's the position the
material is completely equal for four
pawns on the Queen side each one point
on the King side each end again we have
a bishop against the night and well this
position is pretty equal if the game is
being played on both sides of the board
and the position is pretty open then a
bishop will always be slightly better
than a knight so let's see how Nakamura
does this we have King to g2 of course
you want to start bringing your King
into the game rope to f7 not allowing
the King to enter the game via DF file
Bishop to d6 check we have Kings to g7
and now King to g3 Nakamura continues to
bringing his King all the way up to the
Jeep on perhaps if he can get King G
foreign King g5 it will be excellent for
him
Wesley goes Knight to h4 he makes room
for his own King to enter the game via
g6 to protect the g5 pawn king to g4 and
here already the game would be much more
equal if if Wesley proceeded with care
here he played King to g6 and he simply
allowed Nakamura to much a much better
idea would be an active defense with
rook to F to going after Nakamura SKU
inside bonds and here it's very
interesting but after Bishop to g3
attacking both the rock and the knight
look to g2
not allowing Bishop captures here it
seems like white is now able to start
picking up the Queen's at pawns faster
than black but the problem is if rook to
e7 check King f6 and rook captures here
then you get this terrible problem nice
to f5 and now the thread is the rook
captures and g3 checkmate so the rook
will never be able to start picking up
these pawns and here you will not have
any defense you will simply have to move
your King give up the bishop and lose
the game onwards so here you would not
be able to go rook to e7 check and pick
up the pawns you would have to play
passive and the game would be the game
would continue in an equal
here like we said King tg6 was played by
Wesley and a Nakamura immediately went
to look to e6 check so rook to f6
blocking we have rook captures King
captures and now with the rooks are of
the border but now with the rooks of the
board a bishop is actually much better
than a knight
so here Nakamura plays a very nice move
and feel free to pause the video here as
this is basically the only move that
allows Nakamura to play for advantage so
I'll give you a couple of seconds to do
it
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are a remarkable
endgame player and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
Bishop the c7 as the king occupies this
position on a dark square on f6 the
threat is Bishop to d8 check and picking
up the g5 pawn is the king is already
attacking the g5 pawn so there's really
no good way to prevent this king to g6
is played we have Bishop to d8 and now
comes nice - G - Wesley will now try to
pick up he Carlos Queen side bones
we have Bishop captures on g5 now comes
Knights the one attacking the c2 pawn
and Hikaru as this is the endgame and
you do have a past form past points must
be pushed through h4 we have Knight
captures on c2 and now h5 with check
King to h7 and now comes Bishop to d2
again an excellent move taking away a
lot of squares from this Dark Knight so
the only way for this knife to get back
into the game is via D d4 square and
it's very nice how he Cara will use this
attempt of the Knights to get back into
the game to improve the position of his
King so nice to d4 by Wesley so and now
comes King to f4 Knight the e6 check
King to a5 he karo simply keeps on
improving the position of asking Knight
the c5 and Tao comes d4
we have Knight to e4 and now comes
Bishop to f4 and now okay Hikaru did
make a lot of improvements here but
still it's not all that clear how do you
pull this pawn the King is in the path
on a light square you can't move it with
a dark square Bishop so it's very
instructive how Hikaru continues to play
this game we have nice to have two by
Wesley and now comes b3 Wesley decides
to bring the knight back as now the a to
pawn is a very nice target we have
Knight to e4 King to e6 and now this is
very important here Hikaru decides to
start attacking the base of the chain
with his King because the dark because
the black King cannot approach the edge
five point D the bishop and the h5 pawn
are creating a wall here against the
black King so the black King can never
approach the h5 pawn and also the bishop
doesn't allow the the Knights to move to
g3 to attack the pawn so knife the c3
goes after the a to pawn but now a four
we have a five here and here comes King
to d7
b5 by Wesley and here we have a well a
very critical moment of the game where
Hikaru has to decide how to proceed his
position is completely winning but you
it's probably very often if you play a
lot of chess chances are you will
probably get into an endgame like this
and you want to know how to react not in
an interposition that is exactly the
same as this one but perhaps in a
similar position and you will be able to
draw on you know some pattern
recognition techniques to play out your
own game so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the winning move
for white for those of you who were able
to do it once again you are a remarkable
and game player and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's really
not all that difficult to Bishop to d2
you simply attack the night the night is
undefended and if the knight moves let's
say Knight here you simply capture the
a5 pawn and now after captures captures
you have a past H pawn and also a past a
pawn and after the King attacks the H
point you will simply move the bishop
and there's really no good way for the
night to catch up on this point is
simply becoming a queen on the other
hand after Bishop to d2 if you protect
the night if you don't move it then it's
pretty much all the same King captures
in c6 and the black doesn't have any any
any good moves the knight can't move it
has to protect this pawn and the King
will simply go here pick up this pawn
get out of the way and then Queen D a
pawn it's very easy but Hiro Nakamura
did not play Bishop to d2 he played a
different very creative move he played
before
and before especially for a blitz game
it's very hard to counter this move
Wesley played be captures on a 4 and
then Nakamura created a passed pawn
would be captures on a 5 the problem why
Bishop the d2 was better than Nakamura's
idea instead of Wesley's be captured on
a 4 had had Wesley played a capture son
before there would be a lot more game to
this white white would still be winning
but he would have to work much harder
for his meal because after a 5 and now
b3 yes you do stop the past pawn with
Bishop to c1 but now after night to a
two attacking the bishop bishop to a3
you have night the b4 and now black
successfully prevents the white pawn
from being pushed to a6 and you can
never capture the night because then you
cannot prevent this point from queening
so here white would have to continue the
game in a different manner but in the
end most likely would still win it but
you know better to win the game
immediately so that's why after this b5
move Bishop to d2 would have been
immediately winning but okay before we
have B captures on a for Wesley goes
captures the wrong pawn we have B
captures on a5 and now a 3 Nakamura has
to play better up to c1 so he can meet a
2 with Bishop to b2 Wesley goes for it 8
to Bishop to b2 attacks the knight
Knight to a4 and now Bishop to a-1
preventing the point from being pushed
to a 1 but also controlling the squares
the Knights can jump - also you can see
that this point is controlling c5 and
this point is controlling b6 so the
knight can't really move anywhere we
have c5 by Wesley and simply a six by
Nakamura he continues pushing this path
pass pawn C capture son d4 we have a 7
Wesley pushes d3 and in this position if
you thought white should play a 7 and
bring a queen into the game you black
would really just laugh at you and you
will lose terribly as you would fall
victim tonight to b6 check you would
have to move the King and then Knight
captures the Queen and then black would
simply win the game and continue to
laugh at you but after d3 if you simply
decided to move the King let's say King
to c6 lock like Nakamura did in this
game now there are no tricks would night
a b6
check and it was in this position on mu
53 that Wesley so resigned the game now
going into the results of this match in
the five plus one portion then the match
ended equal I believe the result was
five five two five in three plus one
also the result was equal
III also think it was five to five or
four to four it was only in the bullet
section that Nakamura was better than
Wesley so and I believe he won by a
three-point margin so yeah I mean
definitely a tough match for Wesley he
proved that he can take a car win in
five minutes and three minutes but not
in bullet but very few people can do
that obviously one of them being magnus
carlsen
and yeah i mentioned in my previous
video that the only person Hikaru lost
in the speeches championship was Magnus
Carlsen but he actually lost him twice
in 2016 in the finals and in 2017 in the
finals although in 2016 it wasn't yet
called the speech Chess Championship it
was it had a different name but yeah he
didn't lose to him twice in inches coms
finals of this event competition but
yeah that's basically the game I do hope
you enjoy that Hikaru Nakamura is the
2018 speed chess champion so we'll see
if he will be able to continue this run
next year and perhaps he will have to
face Magnus cross and again because this
year Magnus Carlsen did not compete for
for some reason maybe maybe they said
why I can't really remember but yeah
that's the game and I also wanted to
show you what I received today I
received my exclusive photos of Bobby
Fischer there you can see by Harry
Benson it features a lot of cool photos
never before seen by Bobby I mean I've
seen them on the internet some of them
but not all of them really a wonderful
piece and I'm very happy to have that
and on a completely non chess related
subject I also received my Infinity
Gauntlet so very happy to get into that
as well you know to prepare for all the
movies as I mean I've never really been
into comics but I'm fairly
a very happy to start reading this one
so yeah just wanted to share that I
would like to thank with back holding
Oliver purged of all the Michael
Stirling and Peter Mitaka for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous video so your
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content thank you all and
I'll see you soon
[Music]